bonsoir mary ann veneman merci d'être
avec nous ce désengagement du fonds de
pension norvégien klp c'est clairement
un acte politique
oui c'est un acte politique d'abord qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte particulier
puis quand on sort d'une nouvelle dans
un nouveau cycle de violences entre
israéliens et palestiniens il faut pas
oublier que tout ça est encore frais la
dernière flambée flambée de violence qui
a d'ailleurs particulièrement me dit
et puis surtout c'est à un acte
politique en ce qu'il réaffirme le droit
international qui depuis de nos amis et
de côté par les israéliens mais aussi
par une partie de la communauté
internationale qui fait ranger du côté
du côté des termes israélien a été le
cas mais tellement d'administration de
femmes lorsque l'ambassade des états
unis a été de transférer à jérusalem est
qui était l'acte de reconnaissance
implicite de 2 du statut de capitale
d'israël accordé par 30 des familles
tration à jérusalem alors que jérusalem
reste au coeur du conflit et des
tensions on l'a vu très récemment et
donc voilà je le dirai qu effectivement
c'est un peu peut-être inattendu mais
les acteurs économiques font aussi la
politique dans cette région et donc il
faut le voir sous cet angle double alors
le jeu le font expliqué que cette
présence 1 dans les colonies
israéliennes en cisjordanie contribuer à
une violation du droit humain
international au sein des territoires
occupés en quoi est ce le cas alors il
yad'abord violation par que le colis
ryan compte illégales au regard du droit
international elles constituent une
occupation dans les territoires puis il
n'appartient pas à l'état d'israël
et puis surtout le fonds de pension
norvégien accusait dans des couches it
et comme la société denain sud rail et
la sociét'halle femmes pour nos étals de
rendre justement qu'il territoire
attractif pour les colons qui rappelons
le sont enduits music de brantes ifrane
généralement pas ce talent dans les
territoires pour 2 rue gouin
soit des réseaux religieux parce qu'on
parle des juifs orthodoxes qu'il ya que
ces territoires des sionistes ne dure en
liberté territoire a par contre elle il
serait le directeur il est dit
et puis deuxième chose il faut quand
même bien temps de crise du logement en
traîne depuis de longues années qui fait
tiquer territoire sont attractifs pour
des gens qui cherchent des logements des
vies très lent qui cherchent des
logements à bas prix et donc évidemment
étant l'argument fort qui a permis au
gouvernement l'état n'est notamment avec
évidemment appuyé d'extrême droite
israélienne d'appuyer et les
localisations et colony nous donne en
territoire palestinien
et tout cela bien sûr créer une
situation explosive donc y'a quand même
la volonté à mon avis qui sera
d'ailleurs peu d'effet il faut être
réaliste il ya comme la volonté de la
firme et encore une fois le droit
international et le fait que qu'il faut
parvenir à une position en dehors de
cette escalade en tout cas ce se font à
calpe et n'en est pas à son premier coup
d'essai un et c'était déjà désengagé du
plus grand opérateur multiports indien
pour son implication dans un projet de
l'armée birmane
on a clairement l'impression quand on
voit ce genre de choses que
certaines entreprises certains privés en
tout cas sont plus audacieux que les
états eux-mêmes pour peser dans ce genre
de situations qu'ils estiment inégale en
tout cas où il ya les violations de
droits oui plus audacieux on l'a vu
pendant ya quand même un certain nombre
d'actionnaires donc quand même à mon
avis l'abitibien politique bien la ville
rick personnes il sans doute d'ailleurs
a fait face à des oppositions aux stands
amis d'uchon attention parce que je
pense pas qu'il ya un bloc et créatif a
constitué sans doute hippolyte personnes
qui ont voulu faire un geste les
politiques forts bon il est vrai que les
foi font attention contrairement à
l'état mais pas soumis à des obligations
diplomatiques
il explique aussi pourquoi il est très
difficile aujourd'hui pour la communauté
internationale et pour les états puis un
des relations bilatérales avec israël
est très difficile d'influencé israël
layali pression économique qui est très
concrète
il va avoir un impact est perçu comme
étant le seul moyen de faire plier les
israéliens sur un certain nombre de
conditions qu'il va leur poser encore
une fois merci